dude I'm fired up bro why bro take it
easy lobster trucks outside you got the
lobster truck that what to call Maine
lobster rollers husband's cousins
Lobster did you see when he pulled
Russian mobster Yeah right you did he
got so excited he was like standing
there he's like your see a kid jumping
up and down I go what are you doing he
goes look I got what he goes that truck
I go you want to get some now he goes I
sure do Brian yes I do and I go take it
easy we'll walk over it's just right
there he goes there let's go and we walk
over and go stop [ __ ] you know there's
no he couldn't get open I was just an
early again ok merly you can't weigh
Anna's delivered it in the form of a
delicious butter drive D Lobster
no I'm telling how many a [ __ ] out of
that dude I'm telling you you know me
yeah foodies that is the best lobster
roll I've ever had look at the [ __ ] over
the bun has delicious that's thought
that's the key the bun and they don't
[ __ ] around and make you like a lobster
salad with put all this mayonnaise
butter on there hardcore main land
lobster on top I want the wrong one i
want the one with other lemon yeah they
do all that i get not a touch of mayo
maybe just I don't want the male [ __ ]
that's delicious
I'm telling you dude it was so good at
to post about I was like I gotta tell
everybody about this you became that guy
who talks about this [ __ ] is crunk no
crunk dude christmas is here I can't
wait to get down with this stupid show
so I can run down there don't say stupid
this is a dude bro it's our livelihood I
know hold on but I'm gonna do do this
very quickly and short because my mouth
is watering for that stupid lobster
lobster cousins cousins Lobster Trump's
fighter in the kid though the mothership
can you make a lobster roll me yeah you
do you have Lobster on you now right now
cuz they do I don't know the butter not
the butter no soft bun no it's baked by
angels do you have bugs of the sea no we
call lobsters there are Indian crushed
their skeleton system just to greet you
they are they are in the insect queue
family but there's bugs are the sea bro
they are that we douse in [ __ ] butter
yeah I'm not even a big lobster guy no
I'm not a guy mmm crab makes me sick now
dude it was weird when I was a kid I
shrimpy shrimp undersea I love them yeah
now as an older man I look at those
shrimp I find them disgusting yeah
because they're the crustaceans of the
stupid bottom dwellers of the sea same
way there's no nutritional value really
in them no I'm not very good to shrimp
they're not very good to eat cuz I've
eaten when I eat a prawn my face will
blow up into a whole bunch of hives its
hive central I'm mayor of hives ville
okay when I eat prawns and you know the
big ones my spine my face not just on my
face nowhere else my face goes oh cool
you're eating prawns you mind if I give
you a big big red welts on your cheeks
really allergic to shellfish yeah no
just prawns I guess or certain prawns
hmm great so yeah it's a weird thing now
if you want to douse them in the orange
peeled chicken sauce that yeah PF Changs
does I'll [ __ ] with those but even then
I prefer the beef or chicken I don't I'm
telling you I was mr. shrimp at boy yeah
I loved shrimp and then as an older man
I'm I hate shrimp they're the owner of
the comic strip
Ellucian holders now passed away he died
of a bad disease scleroderma great name
solution old was the first guy to
believe in me
and he would put me up at the comic
strip when I was a young comic and I
just it was my home in New York City on
Second Avenue and between I think 83rd
and 84th or a zag and he would he would
always works in a tie and I'd say thanks
for putting me I listen well you're very
talented Brian you're very talented and
all you have to do is keep working hard
and very very sorting and I would go to
dinner with him as he was dying and he
was such a peculiar man because he would
go like this he always lobster we need
lobster and he's a baller huh hey he was
no he'd managed the club he buddies to
find deities yes it was a refined people
spend most of their money on food yes he
was a refined man who never really
settled down there he is
there is no poor head on him well
because he was dying that's squared
squared Irma is the hardening of the
skin laughs around your body he always
lies but not on the forehead yeah
everywhere man it's a terrible disease
really yes
and he didn't diss Altima Li nice guy
though the best the best and and anybody
who is in comedy you know back in back
in the day loved him he knew comedy he
would choose the lineup he basically he
was the heart and soul of the comic
strip out of the Mitzi shore of you if
you talk to Jerry Seinfeld about Lucien
hold it Jerry would be if you talk to
Ryan shot is special
probably it's certainly where Jerry
spent a lot of his formative years with
Lucien hold back Lucien may have been
his first manager I'm not sure but I'm
pretty sure if that that's typing Jerry
Seinfeld comic strip I'm almost positive
he shot a special Jumeirah special was
not to interrupt your be but special was
all his old jokes to show that held up
over time so he redid all his old jokes
back at the club where he started yeah
yeah yeah that's it there you go buddy
there it is that's that I spent all my I
spent my the first five years or
whatever of my comedy life there and I
would always include the best one of the
best clubs still there still there still
there and and and blue cell is the big
one now but but but uptown on the Upper
East Side that's the club and it was it
was a club that had been designed for
comedy so you had the acoustics in that
room are perfect is everything it's
everything you hear the same volume in
the front as you do in the very back and
it's circular how many does it see
probably 250 a beautiful intimate
setting maybe more but and when you're a
young man and you're doing stand-up is
the first time I ever killed in a room
you kill people
no dude no no no I'm sorry I know I'm
out and I should you say first time I
killed yeah now I'm talking about comedy
no but I'm glad you asked and you get up
and it would be this it was this just
see that's not what it looks like
anymore they changed it I don't think so
thank you much but anyway but that's so
I don't think that's it cuz Jerry
Seinfeld did his yeah that's not they
made me and it's the old school way
still yeah but it was such a thing and
we'd all be hanging around doing our
thing and then you'd get in there and do
your standard hanging there too great
hanging by the way the story by the way
it was where Wanda Sykes it was where
everybody you can imagine would did
stand-up it wasn't it wasn't just
correct yeah it was everybody right
there I'd go there every day and well I
have such a nostalgia for look at it
first of all look at it it looks good
it's nothing but a comedy club it's
nothing ever never been anything but a
comedy club it's it's designed as a
comedy club it's just I'm not looking so
cool look I take this cab uptown or I'd
even sometimes walk all the way up and
just get walk right in and it was and
you were on hey B don't you think for us
who was I talking with about this I
forget
big comic anyway don't you think for
economy specials I don't think a theater
is the way to go I think a more intimate
setting to the way to pet it depends and
I would agree it just depends on I like
when you've been doing it you're a big
theatre act and you do a club there's
something really intimate and cool about
that it's a cool feeling like everyone
like the energy in the room into motion
it's either it's don't you're wrong it's
performance great and so many people
just a different vibe I didn't have the
same connection exactly I thought that
it's almost like trance-like there's not
that same kind of I opened for Rogan I
did fifty minutes not 15 but 50 for
Rogan at the Chicago theater in front of
3,500 people I did very well
it was great but but it was not close
can't feel it it's rolling laughter you
can't feel it you don't feel the energy
but like all those humans in one yes
even though it's more people it's just
not now that energy goes somewhere else
yes ma'am there's something so said of
all that you like if you're doing that
Comedy Works in Denver or the Comedy
Store a better club the next how many
works in Denver oh my god and you're
gonna love the comic strip in Edmonton
because it's Canadians and they just
their funniest [ __ ] and it's like Oh
names I've ever only Kansas show I did
was Yuk Yuk's in calculus blood room
yeah it's a great room they get wild
I've had some great shows dude we had
the we had to find the kid team holiday
end-of-the-year dinner last night yes we
did thank you guys for that that was
great I was also drank some wine
everyone got together went to scopa kind
of our own base really ass where we
started had some serious scope of food
wheat Martin drastic graphics came down
we've been with Martin from the very
start so I asked my go dude so what all
do you do
knocks Mary we were his first guy so he
moved from Buffalo yeah Martin story is
interesting because Martin was in
Buffalo New York
Wanda get out was a amazing graphic
designer was actually a white rapper
before that really see that I find you
can find it not know it's hilarious by
the way so he's basically mm from eight
mile but buffalo think buffalo Wow but
amazing skills as far as creativity yeah
do what he does I'm using his his
graphic form are so so he reached out to
both of us he reached out to you and was
it came in I moved to I moved to LA cuz
I'm pursuing my dreams all this stuff
and then he then you sent them to me
like Brandon deals that stuff do with
him so we were the first guys cuz we're
we're the ones that started doing the
covers for the each podcast every
podcast covered be different from a
movie and it just we were his first
client - now Martin frickin works with
let's see Rogan Mike Dolce Theo I mean
everybody everybody buddy glory
kickboxing I mean major brands major
brands he's killin it man
yeah he's my hole he has this whole
little network now that he's doing his
thing and he's self-made and frickin
three kids yep three kids he lives in
Irvine and any graphics you see as far
as the fine the kid goes he's always
been the guy he's the mam all the ads
everything yeah he he did this art for
your special the cover
mm-hm but you never met him right chin
no that was the first time I met a real
life I talk to him every day pretty much
yeah and obviously cats never met him
because she's knew we were talking about
last night this is by far the best team
we've had 100% for 100% there's nothing
looked at cat I was like how long before
you dip out this cat has a special set
of skills she's not here today because
she she's a quitter and she drove to San
Francisco for the holidays oh damn I
love cat but I asked Cali girl how long
tea dip out on us and she's like we'll
give me work and I'm not going anywhere
so we're gonna throw some ideas if I
needed a personal assistant I would hire
her so good she's good in there
no like no [ __ ] there's no [ __ ]
there's no well she was talking and you
were talking about being Korean and
Vietnamese and growing up with
discipline your dad was a rock marine
yeah some of the baddest people on the
planet Korean Marines are no joke and
that you grew up with some serious
discipline as did cat yeah you know we
live now in a society where you're not
supposed to be there's all this new
psychology about it but I don't know man
I'm not that impressed with what
Americans are turning out in comparison
sometimes yeah I don't know dude but cat
and chin and the team are killing it
that was the point
I don't know that age was just talk our
agents kill it man
we have a bunch of eight more agents I
want yours team I want to stop this
first Argentinian these people who
happen to be from Korea and or Asians
Southeast Asia
meaning the finally kids the Korean
Peninsula that's a fun dinner though I
think so too
delicious food I think it's a before we
move on I think we need to address our
good friend yeah well a friend of the
show Randy Couture
yeah I mean we can do that I think you
know there was I don't know if you guys
saw it or not but Bryan and I on current
events we never know what any of the
current events are we have no idea
chin pulls them from other different
avenues different resources whether it's
New York Post MMA fighting New York
Times freaking TMZ whatever it is we
don't create these news headlines we're
not journalists we don't break the news
so if you remember a few episodes ago
chin goes hey did you see the Randy
Couture sex tape and went no bring it up
just spontaneously and what I go is cool
and to speak for it before you go on to
speak for both of us I think at that
point when I'm we saw it we assumed this
was already out there and everybody was
talking about it I mean I think I think
that's fair right it works again we're
not journalists chin didn't do any
hardcore research to bring this out or
pay for the tape where that's not that's
not what we're about that's not what we
do right I assume this was out
everywhere it was in everybody was
talking about so we
our thing as two comedians which i think
is fair to say is two communes that run
a entertainment comedy show is we did
our best to make light of it right what
we didn't know is Randi is in legal
action against the young lady who put
that video out which is illegal it's
actually you know he trusted there are
many as many of you trust this person to
have you know whatever it was and she
recorded it and sold that her gift she's
a scumbag in my opinion you know and
didn't so I'm sorry I'm sorry to
interrupt you but but yeah so I did not
know any of this I don't have any of
these details
Randi is a friend he's been on the show
before and we made light of the
situation the best we could
they went viral it's one of the biggest
moments of our kid history and I did not
know Randy was in legal action against
this young lady who's a scumbag and put
this out there we had no idea so we had
to pull in honor of Randy we pulled the
clip down because it is a lawsuit he's
in the middle of an instant help so we
apologized and Randy we had no idea yeah
and and and you know the last thing they
also beat up Bryan if you have yeah well
the last thing that I wanted to do and I
know you want to do is ridicule Randy
because I have a lot of not what
happened right that's not what I mean
but I but I think that for him with
without without taking in this into a
consideration I saw that we went into it
and I didn't even think about it I
thought it was out there and we're just
commenting on something but if you had
the sex tape I would a device nothing
but and so our we didn't mean any oh
well we certainly didn't mean humiliate
pylon ridicule but the fact is that that
that did happen and so I apologize
because I have enormous respect for him
enormous respect and I don't want to be
I don't want to be somebody who caused
him pain or added to his embarrassment
that's the last thing I want to do as a
comic so I not only do I apologize about
that but let me say this too if
anybody's got a judgment on somebody
who'd irked off you know on a skype
thing with a girl I've done that but I
don't know ten times I've done that more
than he had here's the thing more than
he has hi Aaron T and here's then just
like that
I always knew rain is better fighter
than me wait better that sex tape them
yeah cuz I'd say what my lighting was
not as good about it shredded he looks
like he looks great and it's
understandable he's embarrassed cuz it
was an intimate moment with somebody
that he trusted she [ __ ] him over but
let me say it again and here's the thing
I've done that I've done that more than
he has so if you got a judgment on him
judge me to do post it yeah I will post
it I lost in a nut and why not but
here's the thing so we apologize yeah we
have serious eye on the kid my vet Randy
didn't mean to bring light to that that
tape and right I hope the legal action
does does you justice justice and that
girls [ __ ] I didn't know this so if you
send whatever it is a dick pic of video
of you jacking off if you film if girl
films a video of you having intercourse
and she releases that that that is
against the law I didn't know that I
just thought it was kind of the Wild
West
no I didn't know that either I didn't
either no I had a conversation with a
lawyer last night a few reasons
pertaining to Randy's situation to see
how serious it is oh it's very serious
that lady who leaked that tape you're
[ __ ] man
right it's not it doesn't end well
shitty it's a shame specially here in
the public spotlight day I mean it gets
nasty I've asked dr. how'd it go how it
went with releasing a whole coating [ __ ]
Oh
car car went away excuse me they went
away
yeah and hope holding up millions of
millions of man and should yes and
should but I always thought it was like
Venus and that stuff that like man if
they releases but no no the people if
they released that day I mean especially
for a public figure bottom eyes it's
NASA bottom line is and I speak for you
and I know I can't well we both had
enormous respect for Randy Couture get
enormous respect you talk about Hall of
Fame
yeah Hall of Famer and and and he's a
man of great honesty if he'd even want
to talk about it I'd loved I'm here
sorry I'm defense or make light of it
again because it was late again front
because again if you haven't done
something like that if you haven't then
you're not my friend my so who's even
ever jacked up into a video camera you
cannot join our club right here
everybody in there that he has
guaranteed so it but
with half the effort yeah kids was so
well done yeah and he shredded and he's
off he's awesome he's awesome he's
awfully on a diet for that like it's a
night if I do it tonight yeah so hats
off to anything yeah yeah more bad we
love you and we really do apologize well
everybody but if you are still upset
come on here and beat me I just beat up
I'll take the beating just get an
underhook and yet the [ __ ] I will take
the beating okay I take the we'll do
that honor in honor it'd be good for you
I felt night because you know what I
feel I know I really bad lobster rolls
on me yeah lobster rolls on me there it
is now man you got lobster roll on the
brain I want to give it to Randy that's
my gift i bad here's two lobster rolls
here's the thing about Lou's lobster you
just gonna throw me to the wolves
yeah you're [ __ ] hey because he didn't
beat you up $17 a roll did I mention
that that's a lot of money so last time
they came out starving well I didn't
look at the price I'm rich and so I
didn't look at the price I just walked
up like I'll take two well with tax 42
dollars it's a lot of honey Sam you made
me pay for dinner last night that was a
pretty no identifying the kid did dude
nice try was on my credit card
no they refund it what you talking about
all right come on Oh as no go ahead you
told are you tolar so we give it all the
employees yes guys you get this bonus it
gives a number and they're like oh I
never buddy you guys were like thank you
so much it's so nice you must guys
they're getting in the [ __ ] car
Brendan goes Brian wanted to give you
guys a hundred bucks each that's it so I
was like that's not true yeah it's not
true yeah cheapskate yeah gp's up with
your shoes bro you talk about my crushed
velvet Air Force Ones dude and that was
obtained through on the Christmas gift
because off whites release off White's
released the Air Force one collab and
they're very tough to get like [ __ ]
tough to get and J shop woke up early
came on the app and he told me last
night was gonna do it
no one ever this never works there's
BOTS out those people have insider help
to get the shoes but you have to be luck
of a drawl to get the to order the
the [ __ ] shoes [ __ ] J Texas one
goes look what I got
size 13 headed your way I couldn't
believe it man Wow christmas came early
that and lobster rolls
so dude i'm gonna suck you off no hole
jealous yeah I mean there's not first of
all that's a terrible threat I'm not
interested in that at all in the name of
Randy Thomas whole Jim suck you off and
film it no sue me bro
listen man sue me bro listen me I'm
gonna put on pornhub listen me I don't
want anything like that it's the shoes
the lot roll does suck off I'm not gonna
get ya dude you got to be more I need
you to be more detailed do you not like
the shoes
what no not like a lobster roll not like
a roll I mean I mean the other one you
dick suck in a lobster I'm so confused
dick suck and a lobster roll take second
a lobster rolls good he's empty jinsoyun
sea ice when I educate Brian on these
let me see these shoes that he that I
could give a [ __ ] about I do have to buy
some clothing to you for what I'm
running out and I'm going to sow that go
to Africa Oh buy really nice shiny stuff
and bring it down go on a Cape Town on a
safari no I'm going to Port Elizabeth to
dive with sharks I think or maybe I'm
doing that in Cape Town no I know you
told this wasn't have to do with clothes
though well cuz I need to dress like I
said a gentleman safari er dude oh no no
dress like Indiana Jones well that's
kind of what I want to do I want to get
a hat and paint your face right no why
go on going white face you go white face
so the Sun doesn't bother you you know
if you'll white face then sex don't
bother you you know that from the paint
that's why a lot of people do it well
you know you see like a lot of the
villagers and Aborigine like they always
have light on their face you ever see
that town made all that up you see a
Clint Eastwood movie about what they
made John Huston great director when he
shot an elephant and the African in the
end says he says something in African he
said what he's saying he said white
hunter black heart dude just take that
hey [ __ ] you're hunter
hey Huck those ropes tight you know what
you know you're more likely to find you
know you're a [ __ ] white elephant to
shoot in Africa then those all-white
[ __ ] are those [ __ ] tennis yellow eye
off like Nike collabs hey do you do I
I hate them dude I hate your Porsche I
don't use I hated that jacket you were
wearing that was so expensive last night
it's a nice do you like that that's a
beautiful jacket that's that's right
that's craftsmanship japanese hand
that's that's your Beto's that's that's
a d2 really not for you bro well and
then your stylus lands in he said that
yesterday and I said Eddie Bauer
yesterday this is James purse since in
my shoulders well and I got shoulders on
me from boxing dude you guys know chris
d'elia supposed to be on the show today
I know but Brian we didn't know his
schedule and Chris got very upset yeah
Rajani I was sure trying to get Chris to
the campaign for guest of the year let's
see if he texts me back he just he just
wrote us off call him see what he says
hey guys congrats Bry ruined everything
um call him let's call him my Fiat said
he gets what are you calling them chin
how's your food last night its scope is
gray man it's nice and just amount just
like the perfect amount of salt do you
know I'm saying pasta there's nothing
worse than tomb salty food yeah but I
get the breeze on the taste
um what you got what pot you got the
rigatoni are you the matter I forgot
what the thing was but I think it was a
more expensive one on the menu the pasta
something it was kind of like the square
pastas I did have cheese lumps of cheese
I think so yeah that's the rigatoni
Brian got the same thing no so I didn't
get the rigatoni is something else yet
then I forgot what it was Ronnie
probably not you I got delicious yeah
it's very good and the wine was amazing
and I got a beer there too
oh yeah double IPA was in a can
that ain't no he's good time drive the
dessert I don't think I don't remember
how do you know what the only thing and
you brought to my attention scope it was
so loud I didn't have super dark places
always like hey hold on you're on the
podcast so be respectful all right no I
didn't ruin everything I know
shooting my show and I couldn't
guarantee 10 o'clock and I got here at
10:30
I don't believe him Chris what don't say
whatever it is it's school that's on ABC
be respectful though don't be a dick
already I can already tell you're going
to be a dick nun we air our air date is
January 9th the Goldbergs and I've been
shooting this chauffeur on episode 10 ok
that's so uncool of you man this is my
show I'm living my dream don't [ __ ] all
over my dream no we don't know that dude
and if you're good and you play your
cards right I'll get you a small part on
my show no what no what oh you're so
[ __ ] disrespectful what are you doing
right now he doesn't okay sounds like
you just woke up yeah people want to
know what is Krista Lia doing in your
little house waking up you just wake up
it's 11:32 and you're just waking up now
he says he knows he's guest to the air
baby we have
that their votes haven't come out vote
it's not yeah I will announce this it is
a it is a two-man race and in third in a
far third note no hate on Andrew Santino
but the red sluggers in third the red
sausage a so and forth and after that it
gets dicey but it's good to a Christian
feel you could say master down wow you
gotta know two things one of those
things I agree with the episode hey
Brian I all say over/under five but as
far as guests of the year Chris what are
you with the belt that's do you know his
name don't don't be why is that a
[ __ ] name is saying his name you're
so disrespectful he's he's in the race
with you no he doesn't say that did you
can't just categorize him that way
all right listen what what what are you
what is your dad do you say you just say
fire yeah what's he fire people so when
I say what oh wow so you're just yeah
you know you ignored my question you
decided to say is that your current mood
yeah yeah I see your what again oh dude
you sound like a wild cat you sound like
a [ __ ] mountain lion if you are an
animal do you think you'd be what would
you be it you'd be a stork right what
that animal has not come out yet you're
too cool to be an animal that's actually
living right now you piece of [ __ ] all
right any quiz what animal would you be
what do you what do you got planned
today besides not alive I'm trying to
get people to stop saying hey [ __ ]
what is that what are you with in other
words your reign your name rings a bell
because I think I remember hearing your
name as how you're saying yeah
um today why don't you go to the gym and
workout only your legs and do that for
about I don't grow huh do you think it's
because you've never had any adversity
in your life she never had to really
worry about how to better root yourself
to the ground I know it so they're not
so I'm asking seriously so your legs
being that short and skinny that's not a
condition well sometimes you don't get
enough calcium to one part of your body
well being milk on your legs is not how
you get calcium into your bones
who talked to you about nutrition who's
the guy okay there's Greg an expert well
you don't take you don't don't listen to
Greg anymore also stop posting pictures
of you with your shirt off it's so
annoying all right we'll listen I gotta
go back to the podcast alright no you
don't win yet we'll see you dude we'll
see Chris it's closed we love you love
you man you're good
all right buddy go fly go fly on the
tape lay that top right clip Jim my new
shirt your new shirt
you're Cassius Clay new shirt you a
[ __ ] fighter that's so disrespectful
that you smacked my face a bunch of
times I could literally see your first
salt well black I would make a [ __ ]
my new shirt
look at your new shirt you're Cassius
Clay new shirt I'll tell you what man
did you see this one it's gonna be
closed for him and Thea but this one's
ready watch his mouth that mother [ __ ]
man he's so funny he's so funny lives
for one thing that's to make his brother
said since he was a kid he only lives to
make people laugh he's so shout-out to
Matt Thalia who I'll beat up for no
reason oh wow dude yeah have you met his
brother I've never met oh my god I don't
know silly goose to his dad's also uh
Chris since he started working out he's
getting [ __ ] his dad's a big guys dad
63 Krista's I mean the other day at the
cars only god damn dude you might have
told me you didn't [ __ ] yeah he's got
a jack dude [ __ ] off though you know
that's a great picture Dino
that's a great I'd like to I'd like to
Thrain that [ __ ] too
that's a great shot let's do great
actually I'd really like the frame guys
want to get that picture hmm I'm sure
you can get it dude yeah I love it I
love that picture all right Shane you
gettin excited for the holidays dude um
not as excited as I used to be you don't
say yes I'm not feelin that Christmas we
want for christmas I mean if the
Christmas bonus now see you buy yourself
with anything I wanna buy an island
drive Viper or what does bye Bri please
oh I thought you made a real Viper
snake well I guess they could check it
anywhere if you bought a Dodge Viper see
if you can buy see right now people buy
a Viper online I wonder what you have to
go through you have to have a certain
license to buy a poisonous snake do you
yeah
you can't buy a poisonous snake without
Linda thing you can't you don't do fangs
snakes he do certain ones Vipers you
have to see you can take out there you
take I can take out there yeah but uh Oh
[ __ ] the Jake the snake that you know
his snakes they took the venom they took
the Klan the venomous glands out oh
these pythons where the [ __ ] they were
they they defend but they'd still [ __ ]
you up you saying you get bit by any of
these I'll do I'll take that [ __ ]
sauce kill Palestinians Vipers somebody
we knew inside Arabia got bit by one of
those very cool died badly Jesus Christ
dude baby West African rhino 150 bucks
do you leave it all those for Christmas
you don't wanna know the words no honest
you don't want to be bitten by any of
those now the real badass is that gaboon
viper dude I can bite a desert horned
Viper for 300 bucks yeah you can't click
on that and the couple they do overnight
[ __ ] the cabin viper dude will bite you
dude a green bush Viper
oh so cheap I thought they'd be like in
the thousands yeah I know I was trying
to buy a a lot of eggs true amazing
Vipers almost seamless blending into the
sand alright
silent precise is highly venomous animal
please check your local laws before
purchasing whatever add-to-cart chin
I'll take a male but I'm hey if you guys
that mean shouldn't do this
Add to Cart all right man how do we do
it hold on to rate holds much out of the
cart we can buy it right now 125 so you
don't have a coupon yeah you got it it's
at least 125 bucks for shipping Wow a
desert horn by dude yeah things came
along that's not a plane snakes on a
plane bro dude look at that so it's
basically 450 bucks to get this thing to
us to get a sneak that was kill you and
you could you if you wanted to
assassinate somebody squid would you put
it in their mailbox if you wanted to
kill feel we could just put that thing
in the studio you know you put it if you
put that in somebody's mailbox there was
a guy who tried to kill somebody that
way with a rattlesnake put it in the
guy's mailbox Jesus Christ rattle but if
you put a [ __ ] desert horned Viper
and somebody's Chino back
King Cobra dude if I can buy King Cobra
Oh Ginuwine King Cobra Christmas I will
buy it with my American Express right
now on this podcast would you would you
take care of it for us Jen no no I don't
think so dude think how many [ __ ]
dude you would get but if you had a
[ __ ] king cobra in your apartment I
think's gonna help you could make money
you could pay people hey come check out
my Cobra $5.00 Tim in my apartment check
out my cover of five dollars see what
else see the gaboon viper you ever seen
a gaboon viper just once dude dude a
coral snake in the cobra family
dangerous of coral fare in the cobra
family neurotoxin
holy [ __ ] you i believe i mean god oh
endless do their also oh [ __ ] baby rough
scale chess fallout so doo doo doo death
adder no no dude a baby king cobra no
live on her box what ah [ __ ] this solder
got to be like d grows like 12 [ __ ] dude
i was not by preaching captive breads
davies originating india bangladesh
myanmar cambodia southern China Laos
Thailand Vietnam Malaysia Indonesia and
the Philippines well they're just sold
out on this wild bred reptiles can live
20 years in captivity rolling on what
I'm just using very venomous snake there
as it grows and we'll have enough
potency that a fluid ounce could kill 20
people a fluid ounce could kill 20
people look at me look at my face hey
leave me no you just meet a no [ __ ] no
but I mean don't you got to be very very
careful no we don't chin if I were to
buy you a dangerous snake could you take
care of it if we kept it in the studio
no no I'll be awesome at whoa whoa whoa
okay okay coke aggressive the king cobra
will kill you bite you they'll come at
you look at that look at that bad boy
let's see let's watch that we're gonna
plant one king cobra pet bites owner
this could be huge in pink steve-o damn
fighting for his life
- King Cobra bro his Facebook page shows
le you handling the snake considered to
be one of the most dangerous in the
world why would you [ __ ] that Paul
Oh coz you himself to the hospital but
he didn't make it very far
here's part of the 9-1-1 - hey i just
got bit by camera and i'm on my way to
the hospital to shoot ancestors I've
worried I'm wetting like crazy
oh yeah I'm like panicking you sound
like a man again huh I feel not that he
pulled over and waited for an ambulance
at the hospital he waited hours for an
anti-venom to be delivered from another
state well critical condition Animal
Services officials say that he had about
20 snakes at his home you need to have
your damn like that dude you need to
have [ __ ] Liz that's a Gila monster
any la jeune you wanna kill you need to
have a [ __ ] of stable yeah I mean
yeah and even them in your house but
you're gonna have those dog that bet
kind of stage should we buy an animal
I'll be cold how video that would be
cool to have animals here we should get
a bearded dragon babies are stupid now
they're really cool Guillemots better
yeah get him on some bites here in
trouble bro you can't get one unless you
have money I mean unless you have a life
if we can get a Gila monster yeah we can
I can buy a king cobra right now you
should call animal control and see what
what you have to do no well you got to
be such a [ __ ] about these things cuz
you get it dude
Utah banded gila monsters damn hmm
too small ah sir I need a full-size bro
they give you a bite you're in trouble
yeah that's the point be damn you look
at how these are cost more and snakes
chin you take care of that thing I'll
buy a dude if we buy for the studio outs
wolf if you have to be fed every day
we're screwed
no dude it's one giant rat once a month
thirteen Hyundai they look cool I will
say that but how big do that thing's
[ __ ] how big does it get is that a
baby
big bro huh you know what you could do
is go buy a large boa constrictor now it
was a point we want some more dangerous
you don't want to see you don't wanna do
what a Viper do up to two feet long
Wow can I have a Gila monster as a pet
you've done that well maybe it's it read
the expert pet Gila monster care guide
yeah that's gonna help gills are
venomous
too often bred in captivity and United
States kept his pets that in mind if
your state allows galas to be kept as
pets read on how do we know typing can I
have a pet Gila monster in California I
would imagine California is pretty
strict mm-hmm
because do you ever see home boy i fee
was in New York meta you hear about this
guy had a pet tiger sure did now and a
pet alligator
they both it was like a duel in his
apartment he locked himself in the room
and jump out the window
yeah they like Donna [ __ ] tussle yeah
a little tossing he had to run out an
alligator in a fight he was feeding it
raw chickens what a [ __ ] he lived in an
apartment like a Dilla not in California
these are illegally captured for pets
not permitted yeah if you're like a pet
shop or something or like a zoo thing
you can happen but not you can't you you
cannot have it's the same thing with any
poisonous snake I don't know do you have
put snakes in California what snakes are
banned in California because I've seen
pythons and [ __ ] yeah that's fine but a
poisonous snake you can't have unless
you have a special license sorry buddy
especially not a goddamn couple invite
me I'm gonna do a double in Vipers how
long are their fangs seven inch two
inches long what we want to do is get
one but it's gonna be fun for the
audience because Oh 10 exotic pets that
are in California hybrid cats hold on
John great look at that see that's where
I'm not on board you can that's a Sarah
well I'd be amazing zebra you can all
know you can't bro these are what you
can have you can equal yeah yeah that
guy's right dude how'd that if there's a
mini zebra though here but in a stables
far away and Ventura farms we gotta
drive out there and see it all the time
monitor lizards that'd be pretty cool
those are big pretty an event list
banning hedgehogs bison you can have we
could have a buffalo I don't know if
that's the right move
I would agree it's a buffalo on a house
a wolf dog second generate Elling you
that exact [ __ ] thing is that
Starbucks in the morning it's crazy that
that's it man yes nothing it's so big
yeah
I got it god I hope he's there tomorrow
say loris constrictor snakes yeah yeah
no [ __ ]
- ah - cancel the pet - can be cool
there's a good but they birds are very
smart you don't want to keep a bird in a
cage they dead those dude did you hear
about well I'd love a camel me - I'd
love again well they spit at you if they
like you you're cool if they don't
you're [ __ ] you can suck their tits
didn't get milk out do you ever see a
video where the camel grabs a guy and
picks him up in his head guys about a
shoulder or the head yes mom throws and
kills a gnarly man and I'll stretch as a
guy who you don't wanna [ __ ] with an
ostrich I'll kick you right in your
[ __ ] guts they're so big tarantula
you know [ __ ] man
I doubt you guys are stupid animal yeah
as far as a pet
cool cool and nature foxes are not legal
what hmm he's reading the comments I'm
telling you we could go on the dark web
I have access to it we go on the dark
dark web and order some [ __ ] bro
primates are illegal to own California
cannot oh like monkeys and gorillas and
[ __ ] all the hedgehogs have you seen
them they're actually really cute you
can't have it links know it's a bit
almost white a hedgehog in Denver
they're adorable now they kill out one
went bad yeah my mom's like no I wanted
one because of Sonic the Hedgehog hmm
they don't look anything like that car
dude I wouldn't mind a hybrid cat oh
[ __ ] no dude oh those things yeah nasty
those games those things here yeah my
hedgehog cute as [ __ ] yeah
little wet nose yeah they'd be careful
with the bristles though you go the
wrong way you have some issues there
little cutie pies do these couple hog
lovers she's very cute right
oh there's that Oh a pet dog two million
views jeez that's a lot huge they're
good with their hogs dude hmm we'll have
1.5 million imma give you five seconds
you get three pets and they have to be
pets that you like they can't just be
shitty pets they have to be pets that
you have to interact with every day one
two wait Han dong but yeah give me other
does not like dog cat go yeah no no it's
gotta be three exactly pets and their
pets that you would have to interact
with on a date okay ready go
five king cobra bald eagle future one
the worst idea I've ever heard in my
life
do you know how are you gonna how you
get Bulger's yeah and what are you
bullshitting yeah yeah there's super
cuddly ready for mine mmm
dolphin of course so I can swim it's so
expensive no but I mean the provider you
know Zee dolphin do you call Zee dolphin
at home don't van and dolphin what else
um probably a hyacinth never heard of it
incredible burt and that gives you a
list when you say uh hyacinth hyacinth
is the thing I get an Amazon oh no
that's a vulture dude that's a bearded
vulture look at the size that look at
the size that thing that thing's head is
as big as his no I want the bald Walter
like the ones in the cartoons yeah the
steering ones I'll have a hyacinth and
then I want how do you spell hyacinth
yeah that's a tricky one others plant I
guess that what it's called yeah I'd get
a green in an Amazon or an African Grey
parrot actually african greys are well
they're so smart
well they're just so smart right I get a
[ __ ] dolphin and if I had to know
those things are stupid I grew up with
one named Jake you walk in nose like a
thousand weren't like hello
yeah rounded air think you have very
cool man repeats everything you want
matter of fact that's why I was gonna
bring up this lady had at one of these
pets stupid gray Birds these African
Gray parrots and it it found out because
they have a Lexus it found out that the
lady were talking to it and then things
have come to falling days next thing she
knows her bill went through the roof cuz
he's ordering treats for themselves
[ __ ] crazy little exes sir yes she
had to cancel the members the pair kept
me like uh order beef turkey oh my god
that would give out the address and the
credit card number cuz it [ __ ] how crazy
is that
yeah that's so smart stupid [ __ ] bird
that's so smart
that's hilarious how funny is that
that's great
how do you blame your bird but there
smart african greys such special birds
birds are a stupid animal to keep me
okay part of them know they're really
cuddly I've had two macaws I've had I
had a calico macaw and I had a blue a
blue and gold macaw and they're so
affectionate but they get really
attached is there anything more mean
than having a pet bird in your house and
I greige you don't want to fly never
kept mine in the case might never have
to because they had access to the whole
house I'll just [ __ ] everywhere that
well they they hang on their thing but
the problems they - ooh [ __ ] they'll
treat your tissue everything - yeah and
they're not Birds a [ __ ] up animal one
of the most especially if it's a flying
bird bite your finger off with that beak
oh yeah
oh dude fighting them not to poop either
right that's the one thing they just do
no matter what mine on your hands or
your shoulder a golden an African golden
eagle bring that up those are I mean
just a bud gold Neal those [ __ ]
are those things are standard Eagle yeah
now giant Eagles that's what we saw that
okay the king of the Eagles man yeah you
know once he comes strange is it that
the American animal like the
representation of America's a bald eagle
eagle yeah as opposed to that eagle yeah
like that one looks way cooler yeah
it's bigger too I don't [ __ ] with the
Eagles man good night look at how fierce
they're huh Wow conceit well you go fly
they call me eagle eyes Oh big fan dude
you get some kind of engine yeah well
you guys want to hear that order random
animals yes my hair drastic graphics
Marty rapping oh yeah he sent me this
real quick so this is him rapping that's
what he says
ja to all white rappers
the hustle so real for white rappers
he loves rob dyrdek
that's works turn it up dude will you
this partner with his that crooked
Martin you came a long way my man okay
the bridge yeah this must cost a ton of
money to produce whoo
[Music]
from the furthest one spin no it should
not be religious it's not bad
[Music]
Brad fixes Blackcomb tactics why leave
it up to chance I'm a master ratchet
but just see a Chokin you got big dreams
wat it cutting going on there let me
just keep playing it in Buffalo's finest
[Music]
not back not here huh no no not at all
I've heard way worse wave but way better
than I thought it was good good voices
good way shittier Martin where's [ __ ] no
it's very good very good at all
yeah proud of Martin dude he's come a
long [ __ ] way
yeah there's a lot of stuff that's cool
what if he still raps on this
hard-working guy hard-working yeah but
this ain't gonna work and it was rap as
he did that so that's his only track
though I think he's too hard to find
that what what are you doing no you and
you and Mom could hook up and have a
band dude yeah
maybe I'd be great the fighter and the
kid inspired Colin right what'd he get
all right
shout out to Martin shout out some are
known shout to every white rapper of all
time there you go the Hustle is real all
right
I don't play fortnight do any of you
guys play for a night or do your kids
play for a night nobody like suckin huge
huge huge huge and they have different
different dancing figures and then
Alfonso Ribeiro if you remember him from
Fresh Prince of bel-air he has that
unique dance this is Tom Jones Carlton
dance yeah so he's suing for tonight
because they used that same exact dance
and went for one of the characters suing
them because they used his that dance Oh
check it out let me show you the actual
dance it's exactly the same pretty much
you just wants money huh yeah but check
this onto this guy they copied this
exact dance from Scrubs that guy they
can make millions they're gonna come
after me
millions yeah the game so big Cisco
eight but he did this not too long ago
this is on TMZ where he says he copied
the dance
so I'll show you this real quick from
who oh wait this is a holdup before you
play this yeah this is old video of him
saying he copied the dance yeah it was
older one so his lawyers saying that uh
he just said that in jest like joking
around like I copied but he made the
dance famous but it came from somewhere
else yeah I'll show her
please let's see this was his name the
other guy from er I think Donald Faison
okay their combination all of that okay
oh no it's not Hillary
No so he's saying he was in space
inspire me I'm being funny he said he's
inspired by a query that's Eddie Murphy
they combine those ideas and made it his
own no he still a suit for sure
yeah there's no that's like it so they
might make some serious money off this
silly that's why they're doing it why
else would you do it if anybody oh yeah
so Courtney gosh I remember this when
she play this I remember this oh she's
all this is look at this is Springsteen
she was so cute with Joy's younger
I think she's hotter as an older woman I
don't think she's that cute that gosh
she's so cute I think now she's the
hottest she's ever been so that's the
dance from Courtney Cox and the words
that Eddie said Eddie Murphy - so here's
daddy Murphy one was a bit good work
seeing white people dancing it's an
exact kind of match it is a measure but
it's his own unique style on it that
went viral
he's no monster
his outfit - man it's incredible
everyone always says I saw him live in
concert Jesus Christ ha ha I saw the
rock tour in Psych make sure whatever
you wear it's not too distracting what
colored stuff like that they like Eddie
Murphy's like I do what yeah when I was
a young man
leather Allred although they look really
cool when I first saw so sick he was so
good it's a bummer that he I guess he
started smoking so much weed and it's
not that hard talked about it Kevin Hart
says he has parties as house all the
time every every month in South Carolina
yeah the most fairs Dave Chappelle Kevin
Hart and Sue Prince
shout out to old Brea so they say Eddie
Murphy is hands down the fun
destroys everyone hilarious like you
just just hosting the party cuz how the
heart does if he came right now I'd be
the best coming I believe it like he's
he just doesn't do it he's so
prodigiously talented actually I heard I
think tenth kid really and his girl is
yeah Eddie Murphy we had six yeah III
don't know it's ten I was exactly a
shitload of kids a lot four five six
seven eight nine yeah ten so you just
add the new baby
I said be ten hits wow it's cool he's
had a great life and he's so he's so
stupid talented he's so ridiculously up
his Chi kitchen like that's a guy who
just I I kind of go I don't know how you
do what you do he can do it all all
right
oh no no that's the whole thing she's
she's she's in crisis smoke show to
skirt one's a white girl in Paige you
problem that'd be all right sure don't
keep calm playing with you well I would
you though he's only one of the most
talented guys of all time why wouldn't
she be a smoke Joe Jesus look at her
wow oh my the Murphy Lord well we got
cuter kids oh my god when you're Eddie
when dudes economics babies are so
[ __ ] cute yeah look at that there is
he can't he can't be like hidden right
even has what we did mix baby even black
and Asian paste when their plaque an
agent dude yeah cuz I like a lot of bait
you sir even my kid when they first come
out he like looks like an alien I'll wet
and kind of red with my color but Knicks
babies right from the get-go they're
just [ __ ] yeah the most beautiful people
on the world are those makes babies man
yep well look at a student oh cool
why don't we get started whoa okay let's
start on that car Carlton you definitely
made that up yeah my knee man fortnight
has so much money I see what you're
doing
oh yes why not you soon I'm trying to
think kind of people where would which
would we assume if they took something
from the kid ah never character looks
identical let me let me let me let me
taste one cent what you're really asking
me is this well you really asked me it's
not what I sue them I don't like suing
people we have but if they took
something that we happen to have done
and you said hey do you want this is
really it looked like our catchphrase
this is the question hey Brennan do you
want three million dollars from a
company they can easily afford it that
won't even miss a beat for something
that they stole from you I'd be like yes
do you feel like it when I say I'm Emma
maybe it's just my own insecurities and
I did like when I see out with Carlton I
see that even even and not that I don't
support I see what they're doing even
with the guys that shown Conor McGregor
from the throne the the dolly into the
window a bit amigos act a [ __ ] that's
different kinda yeah that's different
though because now you're seeing
somebody for a perceived injury that you
got I wouldn't do that but you're saying
with this too like this this is not
gonna have anything better so this would
be this your lawyer would say hey
Brendan this is all it happens because
I'm gonna we're gonna we're gonna quote
unquote threatened to sue not suing
we're gonna threaten to sue what happens
is the forty-ninth goes we don't want a
lawsuit what do you want cuz they have
so much yeah there's a million dollar
check and then he says you he says look
after taxes and my commission
I'll put 500 grand into your account
yeah that's a half a million dollars
that takes care of your kids everything
you go yeah because you know why oh by
the way I'm not stealing it it was my
idea and you guys did take the dance
yeah you mean you did take the dance
know some about me flinters when I see
that so totally shouldn't so one time on
Seinfeld I guess there was an episode
about eating the muffin top just the top
of the muffin oh that's what I do and
what's his name Kevin James
had a whole bit on how you just even
know muffin yeah and it was obvious that
there was probably a writer who saw him
he sit in the back of the room and went
and that's fine but and he never sued
him stuff but that would 100% and easily
be something that you know if you could
prove it but you couldn't but there are
certain things where you can make some
money yeah and I'm not a sous guy I've
never I've never been in a lawsuit or
never you know what would you guys do if
like say you guys are both doing your
special and there's like a really big
joke in there that you guys did and then
some of you someone just jacked it why
don't you sue those guys I just write
another one no I'd never sue somebody
for that I've had that happen to me a
couple of times
alright that's gonna happen in a
big-name comic that you guys know tell a
friend of ours yeah oh [ __ ]
mm-hmm that's gonna happen here soon I'm
not as loosey-goosey with with them
Brian I think you're saying like like a
good like a good chunk of whatever and
they released it before is [ __ ] up no
they're not they're you time but then
you're just a bad person you come on sir
usually a piece of [ __ ]
I wouldn't back out all good manners
right new one like no hell no yeah might
come after you yeah I think that's a
different animal Dave doesn't you'll get
found out on the Internet now you can't
get away with that [ __ ] at all you'll
get found out they put it together and
you're like oh [ __ ] Seinfeld rider wants
McDonald's to pay up for the muffin top
idea what is a lot time with those TV
shows yeah there's so many riders you
know that was Amy Schumer's
differentially so many riders I didn't
know they were stealing from me yeah
that's fair you don't because you have a
lot of riders you don't know you know
what else yet Jim um real quick shout
out to cat for the majority of these
current events she sent them even though
she's not here mm-hmm here Lorne
Michaels sending Pete Davidson to rehab
he's been he's that help before though
right so what what is his what is his
drug of choices everything no no I'm
rehab as in like help us help yeah yeah
depression yeah he was on medication he
still thought he talked about that so
saronite live chief Lorne Michaels
axe the sketches with Pete Davidson at
the 11th hour following his desperate
Instagram post on Saturday which we
talked to
previously a source told page six the
decision was taken to give Pete a break
outside a nightie sketches were dropped
for they're leaving rehearsals lauren
has pledged to help all he can including
Sen Pete to get help everyone on the
cast is hugely protective of him we're
off the upset man we've got Dave some
returned the show in the new New Year
once back on air this prompt didn't NYPD
cops to conduct a wellness check at the
30 rock studio wall ariana grande
davison ex turned up to see him but the
comic refused to see her dave still only
made one appearance to induce wow man
hey if any of you guys are suffering
from mental health or depression or
anxiety there's a book called chasing
The Scream and another book that the
author wrote and I listened to him on
sam Harris's podcast is one of the more
recent ones it was one of the more
fascinating things that he said he's a
depression and anxiety expert he also
suffers it from themselves so it's
called chasing The Scream can't remember
his name
Johann something but I recommend it very
highly and I recommend listening to his
podcast with sam Harris it was kind of
mind-blowing you know how it might
really help you with any kind of thing
you're dealing with because a lot of
times the way we approach depression and
mental health is not probably as good as
it could be have you guys ever had
someone that like a close friend or
whatever do something like this right
something like where they're like I
don't I don't want to be here anymore
say things are too tough have you guys
ever had a friend or someone close has
done that had somebody who actually did
it - oh yeah I remember that one yeah no
you know I mean I I'm not an expert I
don't know how to help somebody you know
this guy was smarter than I was so I
didn't know how to talk him out of it I
have just a minute yes the [ __ ] worst
man somebody texted me demon I know I'd
met him before on one of my shows and he
said he said suicide and depression can
be so bad he said think about being in a
sauna where you do you like it's so hot
you gotta get out cuz you're too hot
they said that's what it's like but
there's nowhere to go
can't imagine yeah must be that like
[ __ ] terrible if you can take your
logic your own life
my message to Pete I'm a prompt saying
this was I know he cares about people
especially like the way he influences
young people and my whole thing is is to
him the overall message just someone up
was if you do this you go down the route
of killing yourself then every young kid
who suffers from depression goes P Jason
did he's famous it's [ __ ] I can't do
it if he did it or I definitely should
do it so then you're influenced in those
other people are suffering from who are
you know have the same issues where they
like dude he's famous he's in Santa live
and if it's okay for him to do it then
we can definitely do it and then you get
a ripple effect you don't wanna be that
guy you don't be the guy who gives these
other young [ __ ] kids with mental
sickness the okay to do it yeah he has
Crohn's disease I guess he's in pain a
lot it went down 110 pounds Crohn's
disease
sucks that's crazy and then he was so
like he said so he was sober for a while
because he thought that was what was
causing a lot of the issues and then he
was diagnosed with another mental
disorder and then he was like how [ __ ]
I can be used bipolar bipolar so a lot
of start doing drugs yeah it's not the
drugs so a lot of the the diagnosis so
can sometimes be tricky to beYOU know
it's not an exact science
I don't know when this guy who wrote
chasing The Scream talks about that too
it's like there is an orthodoxy that
doesn't seem to be helping a lot of
people and he gave really bleak numbers
for how antidepressants help like a
certain pub but you have to keep upping
them and then they stop working you know
what they you know what really helps is
[ __ ] weird but a lot of people with
depression working out you know what
else gardening
just as a start as a first thing like as
the first thing getting your hands it is
but but they've done a lot of research
on when you work in the outdoors and
they look at how other countries deal
with depression which is where like they
sit and talk to the person and they give
him a purpose or something else to do
it's very very [ __ ] helpful this this
whole thing that we have so this OPI
opioid crisis what what you'll hear
people talk about is we have to get
opiates out you know we have to ban
opiates that's not the problem the
problem is the
that gets you to do opiates in the first
place you know it's not opiates like
saying guns of the day it's it's what's
going on that you're reaching for that
and that's what you have to attack but
also instituted they if you take it just
for your back pain or whatever else it's
so easy to get so so here's another
common fallacy according to these people
have studied it way more than I've so
you know you say well if you do heroin
for a month you're hooked for life and
you can't get off there are physical
there are physical triggers and hooks no
doubt however in fact cocaine heroin if
somebody changes their lifestyle so in
Zurich in Switzerland I have this
amazing drug program where no one goes
back to heroin you come into the clinic
and this is all same thing in Portugal
you come to the clinic you can do as
much heroin as you want as long as it
doesn't kill you they'll give you
anything you want
you do the heroin no problem now then
they offer services to help you to see
why you're in so much pain and why you
and and then they give you services to
help you find Y meaning in your life
yeah they have almost all of them not
only get off the drug but don't recur so
the idea that heroin is strictly
something that's physically so addictive
you can never get over actually doesn't
bear weight initially a majority though
very addictive but it is addictive it is
addictive but not the way we think of it
it's it's it's a planet people kick it
all the time however they have to get to
the root cause of what's really causing
it it's really interesting like so you
know the rat Park except you know that
thing right about rats where you give
them they put him in a cage to give them
water and then water laced with cocaine
they drink the water so they die yeah
then they had then then the scientists
did rat Park where he created basically
euphoria for rats everything do snacks
sex and they stick same exact thing
water laced with cocaine water just
water they did the cocaine came back to
it a couple times and then there was
never one rat that went back to the
cocaine never one rat that died because
everything was everything was all good
yeah so so a lot of it is not a drug
just cuz they want to be a lot of them
they feel it's on sale on their names
and it's years and years of maybe their
child writing it that you know it's
it's deep pain it's you know they're
trying to numb the pain the hundred-foot
it's also weird because when you took
your what is it vicodin or was something
else
I said oxycontin yeah why when I was on
like vicodin for back pain when the
prescription was out yeah a lot anymore
the thing is I don't know I felt crappy
a fella like heroin opiates are
physically addicting there's no doubt
about that
there's no doubt but the idea that it
you you definitely always when you when
you replace that addiction for a purpose
and a better life and something that
makes you feel better that is how they
get the ball that's how well of course
it is but that's how they that's how in
Zurich and in Portugal that's how they
get you off the drug that's where the
emphasis that's all I'm saying you can
you can you can kick it but you know
look I mean [ __ ] yeah I mean I'm not
another white on yeah
opiate yeah it's killing your
prescription opiates but there's there's
a there's a it's so so in in in England
when England was big went through the
Industrial Revolution and people move to
terrible slums in London and Manchester
and places like that for off the farms
guess what they had an insane insane was
called the gin craze widespread
alcoholism I mean and there were posters
of moms where their babies were falling
downstairs because they were drunk and
that was all true
and and they were like let's get rid of
the gin well no there it is the gin
craze and well in fact what it was was
the exact opposite if these people have
been farmers connected to the land now
we're working these terrible factories
happy yeah that's all so look at that
almost destroyed London yeah and that
crazy widespread addiction and social
devastation what else you got gin we got
this so this guy ended up killing a ton
of deers like he collected hundreds of
deer like buck buck heads and then let
the bodies rot well he wouldn't eat the
meat so now the judge is sensing him to
one year and also he has to watch Bambi
once a month hilarious it's not a bad
idea
I loved Bambi the guy's a sociopath
and hundreds of deer heads I just a
collector of heads but that's cool
that's a weird tactic it's a weird
tactic complete [ __ ] works never no
it's just a [ __ ] pennies a weird
thing right Sweden I got I collect deer
heads oh the deer where trophy bucks
taken illegally mostly at night for
their heads leaving the bodies of the
deer to waste or the wolf's [ __ ] ate
the bodies huh if you're in Connecticut
there no wolves is that worried that
that's Missouri Missouri no wolves in
Missouri attention all right
this Victoria's Secret model is getting
a little backlash because she was eating
a pair at in and out and also Ock and
also exercising outside like they're
calling it fat shaming what I'll show
you the video of her and people are
upset she was eating a pair they're
saying she slashed Jamie because she's
apologizing to her I'm guessing her all
her friends went there after the thing
yeah she was like I'm just meet this
pair in exercise neuro so her friends
are also models I think and they're just
eating vegetables and stuff inside and
in and out so people are saying that
she's fat shaming the people that are
there is she making a protest I'll show
you this real quick so you guys have a
better idea it's the video everyone's
upset about yeah you don't eat in and
out then why are they there that's the
thing that's why people are upset with
her or were like were some people there
did they just go there for this yes see
it's showing off that she's exercising
outside of it that's kind of weird
in fact a publicity thing I guess to get
people to be gassing up publicity she's
so fast yeah she's super late now she's
like this dick animal style she can't
you suck done
hey oh my god you're the best a shorter
more vegetables and fruits outside but
is it a probe I don't get what that it's
very sloppy like you doing it so the
people walking in feel bad about know
she's trying to say don't eat in an hour
eat more vegetables and I'm sitting here
a good example and so I'm gonna work out
so the people going in or like did weep
I'm sure there's a lot of people going I
like I like my life I don't give a [ __ ]
it's just dying for attention yeah
question
yeah [ __ ] up I sell so I mean you're so
faint like you're so hot you are so hot
but I mean she's painfully hot yeah yeah
I know you're a Victoria's Secret model
congratulations you're a Murad genetic
freak but diet yeah you know what it was
just just clumsy
she's just clumsy I'm just so mad at her
me too I'm so pissed off at her yes but
then you know what she could eat no
vendor you'd eat a double still thin
right wash it down with the shakes
Guinea I agree with you it's a little
low man I won't kick around my bed for
eating carrots or nothing but now she
has boobs oh yeah good idea
Thanks what else we got now well I don't
care I don't care about her well you do
vain no she's very OPP - annoying -
annoying it's very sloppy and no point
was proven it was like yeah girl if I
can work out I think those vets was
upfront I in and out yeah does it affect
in and out all right I don't if you guys
have both watched this show yet why
don't Brendan watch to the making of my
first one first one first one sec one I
find my bad I honey did you guys so
boring
laughs I do it's so boring repetitive
okay [ __ ]
did you watch the first one Brian yeah
okay so there's a detective on there
that's suing Netflix and the producers
for defamation
they're saying they calculated things to
make him look like he was you know
messing with evidence and I bet
tampering yeah it's called yeah it's a
[ __ ] in this comment it's called TV
show and they [ __ ] with that they [ __ ]
with the truth
yes so they because they want you
believe one thing that's what most
people who live out there say that
they're they made it seem like he's more
innocent than yeah I bet that's what
they're saying so it creates all this
demand and the story yeah there's a
reason you they're telling a story right
it's a narrative it's their sound of a
narrative they're gonna exaggerate yeah
the truth
that's what yeah yeah I know you guys
love this not this
Elon Musk the tunnel this is a different
thing they're doing they're using a
conveyor belt you see this figure right
at Disneyland yeah so the car if you
have a Tesla it's already capable of
attaching to this conveyor belt and by
the wheels to do it for 200 bucks okay
my Porsche I could I just have to have
them add put these wheels these little
wheels that can fold out on from the
front they're 200 bucks so you can write
this Wow
also why did you see the initial testing
the person went on it was like he was
the bumpiest ride about and he but you
I'm not sure yet the [ __ ] prototype
yeah yes and also he said it was gonna
go a hundred and forty miles an hour and
they were only able to go 40 miles yeah
but again this is the first yeah trial
it's pretty [ __ ] cool look up man
narrow it looks when you're in there
little claustrophobic yeah I think
people would have claustrophobia for
sure yeah and then once it goes there it
lifts up back to the street
there's bumpiest look but there's so
many people in LA in New York where even
if you do that you're still gonna have
traffic true but it's gonna help it's
gonna help you get stuck down there it's
gonna suck before carpool lanes are on
do member those days oh but it's bad
yeah you know I must do it live in his
best life what else you get this so as
you know or as everyone knows you hate
mall Santas a picture went viral on a
Facebook post were Santa I'm all Santa
was kneeling for a world war two vet
that's cool how beautiful right all of
them
you have the exception of solid mall
Santas button generally can't trust them
we know this hmm
what else I think that's all for now
those are good man cool thanks team
those are good yeah old man shot to that
mall Santa oh yeah it looks like he
might be a real Santa Claus for real we
might he looks pretty legit and his
beards not you know very well so I'll be
the real Santa Claus no he keeps up
keeps it up you know that's a real beard
bro your energy levels gone way down
I'm tired huh just got a little tired
I'm like God I can feel it I just got I
was like cuz I woke up so early
you know honey wake up having to wake up
at 5:30 in the morning doesn't work for
me I can't do it cuz I can't fall safe
to a life bro - really mmm good morning
I can I can feel the energy leave your
morning boy yeah what time do you sleep
them right oh that's good if you sleep
at 10 10 ish that's really good sound
you sleepy 5 you have a special blankie
or a pillow you need I don't know you
don't have a special pillow and then I
just get super tired and II crafts me
professional we do podcasts after this
we got I guess coffee baby boy I might
even take a journal officers we got some
time I'm gonna get this [ __ ] Lobster
exactly yeah he's got some time to burn
maybe daddy goes goes and takes a little
nappy-poo and comes back you never know
with me you could do that because your
oldest [ __ ] take naps you do that
yeah I'm a pup
do it please you're going to it don't
you look so tired I'm awake look you're
gonna up here Oh [ __ ] I need to be
tucked I think that's it for this one
man good yes Bret I'm off to South
Africa as you know dude be safe out
there man
I will I'm gonna bring you back up rhino
horn some powder rhino horn is that
allowed I don't know I know it makes me
horny get if you get shoot a rhino for
me kill a lion and yeah maybe yeah maybe
a baby leopard yeah whatever you want to
do dude hold on what do you say bring
back an Aborigine do introduce them to
the States
do you know Aborigine me like what that
what that means you know
people of the land sort of what is it
what is an Aborigine an original thank
you the original people of that place
yeah bring one down so we can introduce
them to the fighting kid and then they
can go tell just bring one back and how
how would I do that I am you have to
forego some dollars yeah just pay them
and say come back so I can well no you
got an ass show me so I can showcase you
how do you know I'm just saying could
introduce them to the state well they
are the Australian Aborigines they might
be tough to convince now one thing when
you're in the outback of Australia
please find one of those guys because
you're gonna starve or get eaten or die
quick and a lot of the explorers an
Australian explorers they would they
would didn't know how to prepare they'd
watch the Aborigines but they didn't
know how to Peterborough and they would
die
Haga Africa what's that we care about
Australia right now you had an Africa
dude I am headed to Africa now I'm in
South Africa I've home to largest tribe
is the Zulu please give us a history
lesson on it yeah let's close it out
with you giving us a history let's shut
down the tar sands look at that
oh sorry but you're gonna be in a more
modern place in yes Cape Town's
apparently amazing and then and produce
or flight dude
fourteen and a half hours insane 14 and
a half [ __ ] hour from New York though
yeah so I gotta fly to New York 620
hours
Oh sir sir hold on are you 20 hours go
back to those girls I fly to beautiful I
fly that to you sorry I fly just realize
I was like oh they're kids III well I I
fly back to my flat in New York
I'll sleep there I'll wake up 10:30 I
get on a plane I'll fly 14 and a half
hours to Cape Town
Oh hand over foot why you go to New York
first though it's the only way cuz
that's how you take the flight from
there it's a direct flight you can't get
a flight from LA to Atlanta or something
where you don't have well it's it's may
as well be New York so it's all no no
the answer is they leave from New York
now III get on a flight from New York
South Africa Airlines I fly 14 and a
half hours I'm gonna get there I'll stay
at the Intercontinental for how
for day I don't know I'll go to there
I'll go there and hang around and maybe
take a nappy poo then I'm gonna get back
on a plane I'm fly two hours to Cape
Town at 22 and then from Cape Town I
think I'm driving so it's gonna be a
great time exhausted you know what you
know how much I know what the thing is
but going there you like guys there's
excitement going there the worse is when
you have a day left of your vacation no
you have to take a 22-hour flight back
from South Africa to get home with kids
with my kids that make sense to me I'm
not that fun either good thing but the
pop is 80 almost wanted to take his
whole family in Africa always wanted to
go on safari I love safari he's never
been in love he has but he it's been a
long time and he watches animal shows
and he's obsessed with animals so he
wants to take the whole family there and
when you're 80 year old dad what has
that wish you do and when he's paying
for all of it that he's paying well
daddy's dropping heavy coin I'll tell
you what take 12 people to South Africa
and flying business class on a safari
you're that fun though well I get to
hang with the whole family I'll be great
well I I am shall we get to it
have fun though buddy you know the
podcasts I have to the set but did I get
to watch lions in the wild I know I've
never seen those before
I mean what are you gonna do turn on the
air to get on your 65 inch flat screen
and watch them on planet Earth as if
you're gonna get your you are diving
with great whites though yeah that's um
I would be down to do but you can do the
other place get seasick though you get
seasick ah hard dude take pills yeah
garlic too they say right garlic yeah I
think it's pills yeah garlic pills work
for sure and move with that boat no no I
heard you should eat garlic and soak
your body and blood and jump in the
water I didn't know sharks love it so
came with a cage all right dude we gotta
get out of here um I was the Ice House
next week Friday Saturday the ice house
two shows Friday to show Saturday
Edmonton January 10th through the 12th
and then San Diego January 19th tickets
almost sold out t vk.com get them good
luck in Africa be hold on hold on
New Year's Eve I'm at the Irvine improv
come see me doing stand-up New Year's
Eve Irvine go see Bryan the kid Callen
this is a fine kid we're out